I I had heard Ken Harris say there's
this guy at Disney's who's supposed to
be tremendous told milk call and milk
told me that he he always had to animate
two minutes of most of the main Disney
characters for Walt to approve it so
milk would take the story drawings and
are the yeah and the designs that mark
might be delivering certainly did a lot
of those and milk would then do two
minutes of it until Walt said that's it
and then Milt said go to the other he
would go to the other guys and Grimm
that milk said when it leaves my desk
gravity gets it and anyway he saw her
for his whole life he was working to
keep the level high all the time and
could never get a stretch on his own so
what happened was on the jungle book for
the first time he was able to do whole
sequences by himself
the thing with animation is so damn
complicated so all this stuff but the
main point is the performance you all
listening you have to learn this stuff
in order to be able to forget it all or
just have it built into your blood and
you can give the performance which is
what the great guys do and anyway here
he does it's it's the tiger comes out
and it it is both a tiger weighing eight
hundred pounds or something and it's
also a caricature of George Saunders at
the same time who did the voice and it's
also a self-portrait of Milt I went back
to my studio in the state of shock and I
set up most of the night
until about 4:00 in the morning I wrote
a very long letter I said dear Milt Kahl
I've heard about you blah blah blah and
I have just seen the jungle book and
there are ten sequences where I noticed
this one hand and I'm assuming it's you
because I've never seen anything like it
and I I wrote I also said I don't know
how the peak that peak of solo
virtuosity I don't see how anybody could
ever reach it I mean you've had the
hothouse Disney thing all those years of
experience and you know starting he was
the lead animator on Pinocchio he
designed the final Pinocchio character
and led lead and you know he'd done all
this stuff and I just said it's I don't
think people like me are ever gonna get
its chance you know we you need to have
all that and and you are obviously a
genius I'm and so I wrote this long
letter you see and sent it off and back
came a letter I had been right on nine
of the sequences the one I missed was
Ali Johnson at the end but he was very
impressed that I had spotted his work
you see cuz there's the first time he's
done all this stuff on his on his own
back a few letters went back and forth
and he was a trout fisherman and he was
coming with his wife to go trout fishing
I'm gonna have to take my coat off for
this he he he this he came to my studio
he says you haven't met him right and
he's a big guy he's both he died
briquettes as a child me so he had this
hunch and slightly but he saw its thing
and the play thing was backlit there was
the there was from the from the was Soho
Square and the light came in with these
big georgian windows this big shape came
in followed by a third wife as well and
then then there was a big door and
there's another big bunch of glass
saying and in came the shape again so I
didn't know what to do like I grabbed I
ran up to him and I started shining his
shoes as as he comes in you see
and he now he has to pass a whole bunch
of these secretaries attractive
secretary and but he doesn't look at the
secretaries he says you don't have to
keep doing that I said yes I do yes I do
and and he said he paused and he said
there's a big painting on the wall bunch
of men's heads any citroen who did that
and I said oh that's one of my paintings
you know that's early stuff and he said
well you could stop shining because you
draw better than me and and I said oh oh
then he says well on the other hand keep
shining because you can I'm a worse so
boy did I get to work and we went
actually we went into the boardroom I
got up and we had a boardroom in here so
he went in and I said oh how do you know
how did you ever get that Tigard away so
much and and be a tiger and the car -
you know how did you ever do that and he
said well I know where the weight is you
see I do it where there's a contact
where a foot contacts the ground before
it takes the weight and before the
muscle you know and then the III I do
this drawing where it's just touching
and then I do the next step and I do it
just where it's just touching and I do
this on a two-legged person or a
four-legged animal and then it makes it
easy to animate you see I've got my
contact positions he said then I go back
in I put in well I put in where the word
takes the weight in the muscles boats
but I put in the middle one and then I
put in the middle of the median he said
I do that and then I fill in all the
other bits and he said and he said
well I've got it wrong way around I
first asked what do you do first and
that's what he said and I said how do
you get the weight and he said well I
know where the weight is and when it's
taking the way the muscles bulging I
know where the weight when it's just
traveling along to the next bit and
where it takes it that's it and that was
a fantastic lesson in two sentences he
did